so you're into dragon ball oh you win
the dragon balls i got something for you
a little bit i go like vegeta
ah slurp this drink
like every time i watch him i feel like
i need to take a shower what is it
today's topic this is a video submitted
by a viewer so we're going to check it
out
these are their stories
[Music]
are you familiar with any of these
rappers not so much i
heard the name but ugh these guys look
goofy
yeah that's coming from me
[Music]
you know what he looks like what okay
i know exactly what to talk about no
hi okay okay
oh he nasty he's crumbsty yeah
is not a word but the wonderful thing
about the english language is that if
you make up words
the word sounds like what you see yeah
people are gonna understand yeah
he's crumbsty yeah this is the type of
dude like he catch you coming off the
gym
and he's like girl let's do it right now
he's like no no i need to go to the
shower he's like nah
right now i want to see how much you
work i want to taste how much
i want to taste the mustard i want to
taste how much you work i like it when
it's musty down there
[Music]
what's happening how old is this cat 12.
hey girl how about some scooby snacks
damn you want to share the lunchable
he looks like a kid at a new school
first recess and he doesn't have any
friends you know what i'm about
you know that i'm at a new school look
okay he's 20.
he's 20. he's 20. man his demeanor is
looking like he's 13.
well this looks illegal young bus [ __ ]
that's what ybn stands for
young bus [ __ ] hey i'm a
relationship expert right
my name is lee chang chang i'm a
relationship expert nice to meet you
nice to meet you
his name is wi-fi wi-fi funeral yo
millennial rappers got the worst name
this guy looks like a gender-neutral
version of sideshow bob
i like it though is that love tatted on
his face yeah
corny [ __ ] any dishes
i like big girls you know he said what
i'm gonna come clean i like my belly
rubs
that's exactly what you said
tonight we think but first
bring me the oars
it's so great i like my belly rubs
yo he's a hood version of job of the
hood
yes nah
i mean i don't know i'm cool i'm cool
like if you want my attention to show me
about ass quick i mean in a pretty face
to match with it and i'm
gone yeah like
i like it that's my dude
that's my dude no that's my dude
strange shooter strange shooter
but i would what you mean what i like
i like head you in you in
okay let's go this guy's a strange
shooter
i ain't mad that's funny so what do you
like to do is that if you
take go on a date i don't really take no
damn i'm trying to figure out man i i
can't take any rappers seriously when
they got braces
i don't know what it is whether there's
something about braces that just screams
i got something stuck in my teeth and it
just it grosses me out
but you know what he's successful so
good for him do you get a lot of
yeah but i feel like i get like more
all type of girls y'all know how i feel
about lewds i don't like it
girls when they hint that they want to
send me i'm like don't bother you don't
like when the girl sends you to fly back
i don't like it because i don't like it
and when they when i know they're going
to send it i tell them not to because
i'm going to be dis
i know they're going to be disappointed
with my reaction so i tell them not to
send it so we don't have to go there i
don't like it because i'm like
pictures don't do nothing for me they
don't heighten they don't get me excited
and i'd rather just smash so i'm like
i'll just wait till i see you that's how
i am about what if you're long distance
i don't do long distance
that's a message how good are you with
your tongue
my tongue yes oh wow you nasty
[Laughter]
yo yo you know what i was about to say
i'm about to say this to all the mothers
that called me gay i understand
wow you nasty
i get it i get it i'm not mad like he's
probably not
but that was suspect that was sauce
are you seeing girl like a dollar bill
yes
that's nice you know what he reminds me
of
every like evil baron in like the lord
of the rings movie you know the fat
gluttonous guys why are you passing
through these lambs
ah that's what he makes me think of are
you single like i died up here
are you yes that's fine
are you yes okay
you would think [ __ ] that rap about
like broads all the time
would know how to act around a woman
they don't when i go out of clubs and i
see people that listen to that and
emulate that
yeah and i listen to how they talk to
ladies
they don't know they don't know what
they're doing they don't know what they
do or they be staring hella awkward
i'm off expecting something to happen
you know which [ __ ] do know aren't
beanies
yeah but they're dead true actually no
they evolved to this just cuz like no
girls caught my attention yeah i feel
like
i feel like it takes a lot for me to
invest myself into a girl
this is the wi-fi needs to just be by
himself did he speak
about him at a third person
the wi-fi the wi-fi is something i
connect myself
to where my phone not with you
emotionally your wi-fi is on one bar and
come down just focus on his career and
make all the money in the world
do you have a girlfriend
this guy just just in his bed like three
times huh huh
is that even possible huh do you have a
girlfriend are you single
oh no you're not single something like
that
it's like this guy never spoke to a girl
it's like the first time he have the
girl's hands
you made me think of those anime last
would be like so where are you going
right now i'm like
are you single yeah like that had more
drive
than whatever he did
you're not sure about it yeah i'm single
you're saying that yeah he tried to get
his composure back trying to look cool
for her no you
it's too late too late so do you
masturbate
[Music]
any crazy stories
damn sounds like you do i
don't why are you here
and what do you want what is your
purpose here
hmm like that's why i would ask like
okay but what do you what do you want
what's all this i mean i'm sure they
signed up for this of course they did so
they act like they don't yeah you don't
i don't believe it i don't get no
interesting stories at the studio
i'm not some bj addict
but listen if anyone starts their
sentence with this
listen i'm not saying this is my fetish
but it's your thing it's your king
it's your thing it's your king and it's
okay but let's not lie
i'm just not saying the fetish for
something but you know
on occasion every week i'm not saying
i'm a booty official
every other day you know i dabble
yo listen if there's booty i eat i work
on cars i clean them rims
everywhere where i could have one i got
one he said i'm not an addict
but anywhere i could get some i had some
card done parking lot done shed done
living room done bathroom done rest area
done roy rogers done oh no i actually
haven't had any
any stories in the studio yeah that's
something i haven't experienced in life
yet honestly
can you be honest with me facts i won't
be lying
any [ __ ] that says facts is definitely
capable of lying
facts don't be lying facts except when
i'm lying
do you remember the last time when you
had a whiskey dick
what is always you don't know well it's
when you're too drunk
and you can get if you ever had it
that's crazy because i honestly i don't
drink you don't drink i don't drink at
all oh wow
every girl could get eric into this
boning loving
you did female inspire you real women
inspired me like strong women like my
mother and you know maya angelou
like that but uh as far as chicken heads
[Music]
oh boy forest chicken heads i am mad at
him
this guy's the one i like the most out
of everybody what is your type
skinny brushes
he just looks like there's a sound
effect that's made every time
his armpit separates from his arm you
know what i'm saying you know i mean
those [ __ ] that's so slimy
there's something really gross about him
so you're into dragon ball
oh you win the dragon balls i got
something for you a little bit
like
like every time i watch him i feel like
i need to take a shower what is it
are you paying for this oh yeah i pray
for it yeah
my [ __ ] uh are you paying for this
yeah of course you know when you're
around me no worries
oh definitely you know i got this thank
you
it was nice talking to you so thank you
for your time and um
are you paying for this yeah i got it
don't even trust thank you
is that the bill like how much it is or
is that the number they're gonna call
for let's go pick up our food
this ain't even no cat burning hey bro
tell me something it's good wine
what's it called don't worry i got it
you got it i got it
look at this damn i'm gonna tell you hey
hey
never mind she got it huh are you paying
for
how much cost
no no no no you're not fake
the way my life set up right now okay
[Laughter]
do we my life set up right now oh man
that's funny i don't even know what the
point where that was
i don't know whatever rappers portray
don't necessarily believe
because that was hilariously awkward to
watch
that was awkward they did not know how
to talk to girls no they don't that's
why they became rappers though
yes to get girls chances are yeah so
they just use their status so i'm mad at
them
uh but this is fun shout out to my
homeboy that was wearing the face mask
he was
respecting social distancing rules
before it were in place
so i liked that uh otherwise that was
pretty much all my thoughts i didn't
really have no chance anything else
but you know what it made me also
realize how little i know about a lot of
these new rappers
well a lot of them are going to be one
hit one wonders yeah see a lot of them
yeah
all right well that's it for today's
video tell us what you guys saw in the
comments below and we want to hear your
opinions that's it
[Music]